dropping the delusion of being born and
dying
I find awake space without name location
or time
this is found by rejecting all
attributes
a process of pure subtraction
metabolizing Pain by entering what I
fear most
departing righteousness
entering repentance
true transformation does not come
without psychological death
an extreme ownership for every feeling
of contraction
not just on the level of the body
before the collective organism
taking on the burden in this lifetime
to be transfigured into the uncreated
light
to be a vessel for the purest frequency
of the Divine to be channeled through
the flesh
what will remain is wholeness and love
a transformative space for catharsis
this Aura is basic needs for all
creative freedom and peaceful playground
Earth
alchemizing all hatred into love
all greed into service
by realizing one is not
the body effortlessly surrenders to
serving the whole
unique cultural attributes can be
celebrated
while grounded in peaceful Unity
it is like holding MDMA therapy sessions
for all Border Wars and billionaires
fearful memories and hoarding Pathways
become extinct
we are left with forgiveness
healing transgenerational trauma
Petty ego interests are seen as empty
and underlying holistic programs emerge
we transmute our budgets of Weaponry
into basic needs prosperity
finally an alien civilization looks and
says
they are ready
as long as you still hate an other
you cannot be initiated
without airing out your most beloved
secrets
you are inauthentic
hiding
fearlessly say what you fear most and be
free of it looming over you
cease entertaining anything that is not
the highest decentralized and prosperous
timeline for Earth
Lose Yourself
and find the whole